una visita que genera incomodidad la
vicepresidenta de Estados Unidos kamela
Harris visitó Corea del Sur provocando
la ira de Corea del Norte quien
respondió con el lanzamiento de un misil
balístico al mar de Japón luego de que
Harris visitara la zona desmilitarizada
que separa a las dos coreas desde donde
arremetió en contra de pyongyang y tras
haber lanzado otros dos el día previo a
su visita
a casi 70 años de la armisticio de Corea
La amenaza de conflicto permanece
latente y no Recuerda que la alianza
entre Estados Unidos y la República de
Corea del Sur está lista para enfrentar
cualquier contingencia reiteramos
nuestro compromiso de defensa con Corea
del Sur este jueves Harry llegó a la
zona desmilitarizada en medio de
ejercicios navales conjuntos entre Corea
del Sur y Estados Unidos que iniciaron
la semana pasada luego de que
funcionarios de seúl aseguraran que Pío
yang se prepara para una posible prueba
nuclear la primera 2017
la funcionaria estadounidense también se
reunió con el presidente surcoreano
jumpsuyole quienes reiteraron su
compromiso con la alianza bilateral
la alianza Corea del Sur Estados Unidos
es un Pilar confiable de apoyo para
defender la libertad la seguridad y la
prosperidad del pueblo coreano y Haré
todo lo posible para fortalecer aún más
nuestra Alianza creo que su visita a
Corea luego de la visita del presidente
byden a seúl en mayo pasado será otro
punto de inflexión para lograr este
objetivo
las armadas de Corea del Sur y Japón
dijeron que realizarán ejercicios anti
submarinos con las fuerzas
estadounidenses este viernes como una
muestra de fuerza ante las amenazas de
Corea del Norte y de china en el
estrecho de Taiwán